[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا مع هذه التغطيه
المتواصله للانتخابات التشديد النصفي في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الانتخابات
كانت ساخنه حتى في التصويت المبكر بعد ان
ادلى 40 مليون امريكي باصواتهم واليوم
ياتي الموعد مع الاقتراع التقليدي
الانتخابات بطبيعه الحال ستكون حاسمه
بالنسبه لمصير السنتين المتبقيتين في
ولايه رئيس جمهيدن الذي يغرد اكثر من مره
داعيا الديمقراطيين للتصويت بينما قد يرسم
النصر الجمهوريين فيها طريقه عوده عوده
دونالد ترامب للبيت الابيض
ولكن الاهم ان تصوتوا انها انتخابات مهمه
جدا واتمنى ان يحدث الصواب اعتقد ان اول
شيء يجب التركيز عليه هو الجريمه وتخفيض
الضرائب لدينا اكبر ضرائب في التاريخ
وسيواصل الديمقراطيون رفعها ويجب اغلاق
الحدود ولذلك اعتقد انه من المهم مواصله
اغلاق الحدود وتخفيض الضرائب اعتقد ان
الثلاثاء المقبل سيحمل اخبار مثيره واتطلع
لرؤيتكم في مرال لكم
اعلنت ولايات ايليناوي تعرضها لهجوم
الكتروني سيؤثر على عمليه التصويت في
انتخابات التجديد النصفي واضافت سلطات
الولايه ان الهجوم سيجعل الوصول الى
معلومات عن عمليه الاقتراع ومراكز التصويت
اكثر صعوبه واكدت سلطات الينوي ان الهجوم
الالكترونيه هدفه زعزعت استقرار
الديمقراطيه في امريكا
قبل ذلك كانت ام بي سي نيوز نقلت عن مسؤول
امريكي كبير قوله ان وكاله الدفاع عن
البنيه التحتيه لا ترى تهديدات الكترونيه
كبيره على الانتخابات مؤكدا انها كانت
تستعد خلال العامين الماضيين لاي تهديدات
المحتمله وبرز امن الانتخابات كقضيه
رئيسيه في الولايات المتحده بعد ان تم
انتهام روسيا بالتدخلي في الانتخابات
الامريكيه لعام 2016 بحمله قرصنه ودعايه
مضاده
[موسيقى]
وقرر مسؤولوا مدينه فيلادلفيا اجراء تعديل
في اللوائح الانتخابيه يقضي التدقيق في
قوائم الناخبين من اجل منع التصويت
المزدوج وتعني هذه الخطوه مقارنه قوائم
الناخبين الذين صوتوا من خلال البريد
بقوائم الناخبين الذين ادلوا باصواتهم في
السنه
هذا الاجراء تحديدا ان يؤخر الاعلان عن
النتيجه النهائيه للولايه انقسم الحزب
الجمهوري مشاهدينا منذ ظهور دونالد ترامب
في المشهد السياسي الى جناحين الجمهوريون
التابعون لترامب والجمهوريون التقليديون
القسم الاخير تعرض لهجوم الرئيس السابق
بسبب اختلاف خياراتهم السياسيه حتى انه
عمل على الحشد ضدهم في الانتخابات النصفيه
قدام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الرجل الى محور الحراك في الحزب الجمهوري
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
في انشقاقات عميقه في الحزب الجمهوري
جديد جديد
اليوم السادس من يناير من عام 2021 عندما
اقتحم المئات من انصارهم مبنى الكونجرس
رافضين نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي
اطحترامب لصالح منافسه الديمقراطي
قائمه خصومه ترامب داخل الحزب الجمهوري
زادت بعد احداث الكونجرس التي اداناها عدد
من قاده الحزب بل وايدوا اجراء تحقيقات في
حق ترامب بشان دوره في التحريض عليها
قائمه خصوم ترامب من الجمهوريين تشمل
سيناتور ميتروني عن ولايته وهو ايضا
المرشح الخاسر في انتخابات الرئاسه لعام
2012 امام الرئيس السابق باراك اوباما لفت
الروم للانتباها اليه حين اصبح سيناتور
الوحيد الذي يصوت ضد رئيس من حزبه في
محاكمه عزل ترامب عام 2020 وتلقى حين ها
ده فعل غاضبه من زملائه الجمهوريه هناك
ايضا عضو مجلس النواب عن ولايه ويومينغ
ليست تشينغ احد اشرس منتقدي ترامب شغلت
منصب نائب رئيس اللجنه التي شكلها
الكونغرس للتحقيق في احداث السادس من
يناير عقبها ترامب بدعم منافساتها في
الانتخابات التمهيديه في الولايه هاريت
هايمان فخسرت تشين فرصتها في الترشح مجددا
لمجلس النواب وايضا هناك النائب الجمهوري
ادم كنزنجر عضو اخر في لجنه التحقيق ضد
ترامب وعرف بدعمه لمرشحين الديمقراطيين
يواجهون مرشحين من الجمهوريين يدعمه
قراره بعدم الترشح لاعاده انتخابه اثار
التكهنات ان الاسباب وراء ذلك هي مخاوف
وكنزنجر من ان يواجه ذات المصير الذي لحق
بزميلاته تشيني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في عام 2001
سيناتور الجمهوريه المعتدله عن الاشكال
ليز موركوفسكي ترامب للاستقاله بعد اعمال
العنف التي شهدها مقر الكونجرس وكانت
حينها اول عضو جمهوريه في مجلس الشيوخ
يطالب بذلك لم ينسى لها ترامب موقفها ورد
لها الضربه هذا العام بدعمه كيليشي باكا
وبذلك فتحت المعارك التي يخوضها ترامب
داخل حزبه الجمهوري واختلاف الحسابات
والمصالح بينهم باب الانقسام داخل الحزب
[موسيقى]
استاذ وليد
والشام
[موسيقى]
فيديو
الله يحفظك
مراسل العربيه
حدثنا عن الاجواء عندك بن سلفانيا
فيها معركه ساخنه بين اوزو وايضا
اولا ربما يبدو لك المكان وكانه مكان عادي
وفارق ولكنه في الحقيقه هو مدرسه ثانويه
عليا والباب خلفي يستقبل الناخبين في
الداخل لا يحق لنا بالتصوير ولكن استطيع
ان اجزم على ان نسبه التصويت وصلت الى
اكثر من 40% من الاشخاص المسجلين في هذا
المكان المسؤول عن قلم الاقتراع اكد لي ان
هذه النسبه هي النسبه عاليه الى حد ماء
ربما نصل الى 60% في نهايتها هذا اليوم
ماذا يعني ذلك يعني ان الطرفين المعنيين
بهذه الانتخابات استطاعوا تحريك
الناخبين الى حد ما ولكن لم يستطيعوا
التحريك جماهير لتكون صفوف طويله امام
مراكز الاقتراع طبعا استطلاعات الراي تقول
ان الارقام وتقاربه جدا بين المرشحين
المرشحين لمنصب مقعد مجلس الشيوخ نامت اوز
و ااا جون فترمان ما نشاهده في مكان مثل
هذا هو بالفعل هذا التنوع في الناخبين ومن
الواضح ان النصف يصوت لفتر منصف اخر يصور
وسوف تكون الارقام متقاربه جدا
في عمليه الاقتراع عندك وماذا تقول
استطلاعات الرائحه حتى الساعه
الاستطلاعات الراي تقول انها متقاربه
وعمليه الانتخابات سائره على قدم وساق ااه
محطات الاقتراع لن تقلق ابواب لم تغلق
ابوابها الا بعد اربع ساعات ونصف من الان
لذلك بعد انصراف
المواطنين من اعمالهم ومكاتب من اليوم ليس
عطله رسميه همم سيتوجهون بعد الساعه
الخامسه السادسه مساء للتصوير راينا منهم
اعدادا كبيره هذا الصباح الساعه السادسه
والسابعه صباحا قبل ذهابه من العمل ولكن
حتى هذه اللحظه لا نعرف تماما من هو
المتقدم نتيجه لن تكون مبهره بالنسبه
للمشاكلهم كثيره ومنها عدم شعبيه الرئيس
وفي ال400% وايضا ارتفاع اسعار الوقود
والغذاء
بالاضافه الى
زياد وارتفاع معدل جريمه هنا في هذه
الولايه اعطيك مثال راويه هنا في مدينه
نيويورك في في قطارات الانفاق بلغت نسب
القتلى من الجرائم نسبه لم تبلغها همم
لعشرات السنين لذلك مساله حفظ الامن
وسلامه المواطنين كانت من اكبر همم
القضايا التي اهتم بها جلد وهو المنافس
لحاكم في الولايه على منصب همم حاكم هذه
الولايه طبعا حاكم الولايه هو رئيس
الحكومه المحليه للولايه قائد القوات
العسكريه للولايه تقع على كتفي او كتفيها
ومسؤوليه تطبيق قوانين ولايه ويمنه او
يمكنها الموافق على القوانين التي يشارعها
ومشرعون ولايه او وقتها اذن لو فاز حتى
الجمهوريين او الجمهوريون همم
[موسيقى]
المحلي او مجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ
التابع للولايه المشرعين
يمكن لي زالدن وهو جمهوري ان يوقف هذه
التشريعات لانه جمهوري
وولاء لترامب وولاء
عن اهتمامات المواطن في بن سلفانيا ما
اولوياته هل الامن ام ال- التضخم العالي
جدا الذي وصل الى مستويات مرتفعه اكثر من
40 عاما في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اعتقد ان السؤال موجه لي شكرا
ال ال المواطنين في هذه الولايه منقسمون
بشكل كبير جدا حول هذه القضايا كما انهم
منقسمنا حزبيا الجمهوريون سوف يصوطون مع
جمهوريين طبعا الديمقراطيون سوف يصوتون
لمصلحه الديمقراطيين ولكن هناك نسبه عاليه
جدا من المستقلين وهم منقسمون حول قضيتين
كبيرتين القضيه الاولى هي قضيه الاقتصاد
الغلاء والتضخم والقضيه الثانيه هي قضيه
حقوق المراه خصوصا عندما يتعلق الموضوع
بشؤون الاجهاض من الواضح انك تستطيعين ان
تجدي في منزل واحد رجل مع زوجته الرجل
يصوت الجمهوريين بسبب قضيه الغلاء ولانه
يثق بالجمهوريه اكثر لحل مشكله التضخم
فيما ان الزوجه والابنه سوف تصوتنا لمصلحه
الديمقراطيين الموضوع ليس على مستوى
الولايات كلها
لكن هو موضوع شخصي بالنسبه للناخبين وهذا
ما يجعل
الاستطلاعات متقاربه جدا فالانقسام كبير
ليس على مستوى الشارع على ملكه فقط انما
ايضا على مستوى العائله الوحيده ااه طلال
هناك قلق من التصويت بالبريد ووصول البريد
في موعد و- اا مخاوف من تكرار ما حصل
بالانتخابات الماضيه ما هو الوضع بالنسبه
لهذه النقطه تحديدا عندك
نقطه مهمه جدا في ولايه نيوز لم تشهد حتى
هذه اللحظه اي همم قضايا قضائيه في
المحاكم حول البريد ولا اتهامات
بالتزويق
25% من النافلين الامريكيين يقدمون او
يصوتون بريديا لذلك لن تظهر هذه النتائج
الليله 25% عدد كبير 13 مليون همم 100.000
ناخذ في هذه الولايه ديمقراطيه او جمهوريه
ولكن 25
25% منهم صوتوا بريديه مليون ونصف منهم
صوت ايضا مبكرا هذه لن تفرز وفقا لقوانين
هذه الولايه الا بعد اغلاق مراكز الاقتراع
الساعه التاسعه همم هذا المساء الثانيه
صباحا بالتوقيت جرينتش
ولذا لن نكتشف من هو الفائز او ربما اليوم
او ليومين ولكن هناك اهميه كبيره يعطوها
لمنصب حاكم الولايه ولمن منصب زعيم
الديمقراطيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الذي يواجه التنافسيه كبيره من همم مرشح
جمهوري هنا في و لاول مره وذلك بسبب بسبب
عدم رضاء الاغلبيه من المواطنين على سياسه
الاداره الامريكيه برئاسه
لاسالك عن بنسلفانيا هل يمكن ان تتاخر
النتائج بالظهور وما اهميه السيطره على
هذه الولايه بالنسبه للديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين باختصار لو سمحت
اولا عمليه الفرز سوف تبدا عند الساعه
الثامنه بالتوقيت المحلي عندما ينتهي
الاقتراع ليس بحسب القانون من حق الصناديق
ان تفتح وان تبدا عمليه الفرز اا حتى
بالنسبه للاصوات البريديه لا يبدا الا
عندما تنتهي عمليه الاقتراع في هذا اليوم
اهميه هذا الموضوع بالنسبه للانتخابات
مركز عضو في مجلس الشيوخ
العضو الحالي الذي لا يريد ان يخوض
الانتخابات ويجدد لنفسه هو جمهوري ولو
تمكن الديمقراطيون من اخذ هذا المقعد
سيكون ذلك انتصارا كبيرا ومؤشرا على تغير
رجعي بالنسبه للولايه فبعد ما ذهبت الى
الجمهوريين تعود الان الى الديمقراطيه
شكرا جزيلا لكما اذا من نيويورك مراسل
العربيه طلال الحاج وايضا من مدينه هيرشي
في ولايه ميسلفانيا بيار غانم شكرا
وهي قضيه رعايه صحيه لذا اراها كذلك انا
ايضا اصوت للقضايا الاقتصاديه والحقوق
الاساسيه للافراد
لانه بشكل عام في نيويورك اذا كان لدينا
حاكم جمهوري فهم ليسوا مثل الجناح اليمني
كالولايات الاخرى امل ان نحصل على مزيج
افضل من المرشحين ويتمكن خلال جانبين من
العمل معا لحل مشكلاتنا بدلا من القتال ضد
بعضهما البعض
انه امر مخيف الاعتقاد بانني يورك يمكن ان
يكون لها حاكم جمهوري ان جزء من نقابه
الممرضات لذا لدينا حمله كبيره للخروج
للتصويت
يدخل الرئيس الامريكي جوب وايضا
الانتخابات النصفيه وهو يضع حزبه في موقف
صعب للغايه شعبيه الرجل اخذه في التاكل
والسبب الرئيسي في هذا يعود الى الاقتصاد
نقطه ضعفه الكبيره قبل الانتخابات انتقد
بايضا قرار بلاس في خفض انتاج النفط ذلك
لانه حاول خفض الاسعار ليدخل الانتخابات
وبيده ورقه رابحه دون الالتفاف الى الحاجه
الحقيقيه للسوق واصلحتي الاقتصاد العالم
ازمه امريكا مع النفط بدات مع دخول
الجوبايدن المكتبه البيضاوي قرر الرئيس
السادس والاربعون وقفه منحي تراخيص
واذونات جديده للتنقيب عن النفط والغاز في
الاراضي الفيدراليه مشكله اولى من صنع يد
الرئيس فاقمها بمشكله ثانيه قرار بضرب
مشروع انابيب كيستون الاستراتيجي مع كندا
الذي يستطيع نقل تقريبا نحو مليون برميل
يوميا الى ساحل خليج الولايات المتحده
اوقفه كما اشرنا بيضا بعد ان اجازه الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ضمن استراتيجيه
ادارته لتعزيز امن الطاقه في امريكا
اكثر من ذلك قاوم بعد الضغوط التي مارستها
كندا على الولايات المتحده لاحياء خط
انابيب كيستون اكس ال تعويضا عن الامدادات
الروسيه الخاضعه للعقوبات لكن لمشكله
النفط في الولايات المتحده جانب وسبب مزمن
ايضا
ليست كلها من صنع اخطاء بيضا الذي يعرف
عنه اصلا تواجه نحو الطاقات المتجدده
بموازاه استراتيجيه خفض الاستثمارات في
قطاع استخراج النفط وتكريره فالادارات
الامريكيه المتعاقبه في العقدين الماضيين
اهملت قضيه صيانه واستثمار مصافي تكرير
النفط
متلو بايدا يسر الديمقراطيون على
استراتيجيات تحديد سقف مرتفع لمواصفات
الوقود تتسبب بمشاكل في الامدادات وارتفاع
الاسعار بالطبع بالارقام ايضا تراجع عدد
المصافي 13 بالمئه خلال عشر سنوات رقم هو
الادنى
يحجز خبراء بان ارتفاع الاسعار في
الولايات المتحده يعود الى نقص القدره على
تحويل النفط الى وقود وبالتالي تراجع
المعروض في السوق الداخليه بالارقام شكل
الهامش بين اسعار النفط الخام والمنتجات
المكرره نحو 20 دولارا نقلتها الحرب
الاوكرانيه الى عتبه السبعين الدولارات
عامل اخر يضع بثقله المعنوي العلاقه
السيئه بين بيض وشركات النفط الامريكيه
الجمهوريون يتهمون الرئيسه بالاضرار
بشركات النفط العملاقه واذ قال قدره
انتاجها بالضرائب المبالغه بها والقيود
القانونيه والتشريعيه اذا اضفنا الى سلسله
هذه المشاكل الداخليه عامل الطبيعه اعني
هنا الاعاصير التي تتسبب في التوقف مصافي
التكرير او تراجع قدرتيكر فيها ايضا يعود
انخفاض مخزون البنزين الى اغلاق المصافي
بحجه عدم ربحتها الكبيره لماذا لم تعد
مربحه بسبب القوانين البيئيه الصارمه
والضرائب كما اشعرنا فالمشكله اذا تقنيه
بحث لكنها لماذا اخذت هذا البعض والسجال
الذي وصل الى حد اتهام قرار اوبك كلاس
لا يتحمل بيض مسؤوليه اسعار الطاقه وفق
بلومبرج هناك عوامل عده متعلقه به لعب
الدورا مهما خصوماته لشركات النفط وتعهده
بوقف استخدام الوقود الاحفوري ضمن مجموعه
من العوامل الاخرى طبعا افقدت قدره السوق
طاقه الامريكيه على التعامل بمرونه مع
صدمه الاسعار
مع امتحان انتخابين لولايته في الثامن من
نوفمبر
سلاح سياسي بوجه سلعه حيويه اقتصاديه بحث
ليس لامريكا فحسب بل للعلم
وانضم الينا من واشنطن الخبير في الشان
الامريكي والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس
اهلا بك السيد ايهاب يعني اغلب او كل
استطلاعات الراي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تجمع على انه ما يهم المواطن
الامريكيه هو اسعار الطاقه هو التضخم
المرتفع جدا والمعيشه التي انهكت كاهله
بالوقت الذي
يتمحور في خطاب الديمقراطيين حول
تهديد النظام الديمقراطي في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
البعد يقول بانه هذا الخطاب هو للتغطيه
على
السياسات الاقتصاديه الفاشله لاداره بيضا
ما رايك
بدون اقتصاد قوي لا يتفقان
والديمقراطيون يعلمون جيدا ان المواطن
الامريكي اليوم الذي يعاني بسبب القرارات
السيئه الداخليه وخارجيا لاداره الرئيس
يفكر ماليا في تغيير توجهه اذا كان
ديمقراطيا سينتقب الجمهوريين لماذا لان
لديهم اجنده اقتصاديه واضحه وهنا احب ان
نذكر بموقف الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
عندما كان رئيسا للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه استطاع ان يرفع مؤشرات البورصه
الامريكيه 25,000 نقطه في فتره حكمه وكان
يسير في الاتجاه الصحيح اقتصاديا حتى انه
كان وقع اتفاقا اقتصاديا كبيرا مع الصين
للاسف لم يظهر الى النور بالشكل المطلوب
لانه بعد ذلك بعد ذلك بعد ان ترك البيت
الابيض اداره همم يعني اداره توجهت الى
معادات الصين بشكل تجاري
وسياسي وربما نشات عسكريه بشكل باخر تزداد
وتيرتها خلال هذه الفتره المواطن الامريكي
اصبح يهتم بالملفات الخارجيه لانها اصبحت
تؤثر عليه داخليا فمهما قال لها
الديمقراطيون ان ااه حقوق الاجهاض
والتعليم والصحه الى اخره من هذه الشعرات
الكبيره التي رفعوها ابان الحمله
الانتخابيه للرئيس جو بايدن همم
اليوم سنتحدث سيد ايهاب عن نقطه اهتمام
المواطن الامريكي بالشؤون الخارجيه لانها
اصبحت تهم وتؤثر على الداخل خاصه الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه ولكن اسعار الطاقه
كانت ماده للسجاد بين الحزبين الديمقراطي
والجمهوري بالايام الماضيه ما تصورك لشكل
هذا السجال عندما يدخل الى الكونغرس
سيكون اييي ضاريا جدا السبب في ذلك كما
ذكرت حضرتك انا جو بايدن وديمقراطين عاده
يعادون قطاع الطاقه الاحفوريه والنفط
المستخرج من الارض
ويعتقدون ان التوجه الى الطاقه النظيفه
والمستحدثه والمستدامه والمستجده الى اخره
من هذه المسميات هو الافضل نتفق مع ذلك
التوجه جميل لكن لا تستطيع ان تعادي قطاع
نفط يعني العاملون فيه يبلغون ملايين
الاشخاص بشكل مباشر وغير مباشر يعني كل
هؤلاء اذا ما نظرنا بصوره براجماتيه بحته
همم سياسيه ستخسر اصواتهم في الانتخابات
والديمقراطيون بالفعل يخسرون هذه الاصوات
دائما في الانتخابات وزاد الطينه بالله
همم توجه الرئيس
المباشر لهذه لهذه الشركات واليوم يقوم
بفرض بتهديد بفرض المزيد من الضرائب ومنع
استخراج همم تصاريح للتنقيب عن النفط داخل
الولايات المتحده كل هذه الامور ستؤجل
الراعي داخل الكونجرس خاصه اذا ما استطاع
الجمهوريون السيطره على كاندريس اعتقد
انهم ربما سيزيدون عكس ديمقراطين
الاستثمارات في مجال النفط الاستخراج
النفط الاحفوري ان ذلك في نهايه المطاف
سيزيد من الاحتياط الاستراتيجي الامريكي
ويساهم في خفض اسعار النفط التي نعاني
منها بشكل مباشر ارتفاع جالون البنزين
اليوم بشكل كبير ااثر علينا يعني
الجمهوريين هدد وقال لن نوفر شيكا على
بياض اا لدعم الحرب همم الاوكرانيه دعم
الجيش الاوكراني فعليا ما المتاعب التي
يمكن ان تواجهها اداره بيضا بالسنتين
القادمه
لحين الانتخابات القادمه بملف اوكرانيا
تحديدا
ستكون هناك مواجهات قويه جدا بين
الكاونجرس بمجلسيه او حتى نواب او شيوخ
اذا مسيطر عليه الجمهوريون ستكون هناك
مشاكل كبيره جدا في هذا الاطار لن يوقعه
بالفعل شيء كان على بياض لاوكرانيا وسيكون
الدعم الاوكراني محدود بشكل كبير وهذا
سيضع رئيس جو بايدن همم في شكل حارس جدا
امام حلفائه الاوروبيين
وامامسكي واربما ياتي بالنفع بالمناسبه
يعني لا اقول انه سيكون شيئا همم سلبي فقط
بنقطه انه ربما بسبب قله الدعم الامريكي
العسكري المباشر الذي سيقدم اذا ما فاز
الجمهوريون
يفكرز لانسكي في ذلك التوقيت بصوره
براغماتيه ايضا بوقف هذه الحرب ومحاوله
الجلوس الى روسيا دون ااا يعني الاعتداد
بالموقف الامريكي لان ذلك الموقف سيتغير
كثيرا عند اذن وربما هو الذي يطلب هو بشكل
مباشر من بوتن اللقاء وربما يرضخ حتى لبعض
المطالب الروسيه ربما يرضخ لها كلها وعلى
الاقل تقدير سيفتح مجانا للحوار ربما يشرك
قوى غربيه ربما يشرك الجمهوريين انفسهم في
حواره بينهم وبين الروس ويكون فيه
الاوكرانيون حاضرون ايضا يعني يعني هذا
الامر متاح وقابل جدا للتحقيق الخبير في
الشان الامريكي والع هتدوليها ايهاب عباس
شكرا جزيلا لك
فاصل مشاهدينا ونتابع هذه التغطيه
للانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه فقمعنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد حول
نيه وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد ارسنال من
منصبه بعد انتخابات التجديد النصفي واكد
ان اوستن يواصل تاديه
نعم
ولكن ما يلفت الانتباه ويمكن اعتباره
سابقه في الولايات المتحده ما زعم التزوير
الالاف من الطعون تمت ملاحظتها في عمليه
التسجيل للناخبين في الولايات لعده اسباب
ما اثر على الثقه في الانتخابات خاصه مع
تصريحات لعدد من المرشحين الجمهوريين حول
امكانيات التزوير هو رفض عدد كبير منهم
التعاهد بقولهم النتائج مهما كانت
[موسيقى]
يتجه الامريكيون في الثامن من نوفمبر
المقبل الى صناديق الاقتراع للمشاركه في
انتخابات التجديد النصفي للكونغرس وسط
مخاوف كبيره وترقب في الولايات والمقاطعات
الامريكيه حول سير العمليه الانتخابيه
ونزهتها
انها المره الاولى التي تاخذها كذا مخاوف
حديثا كبيرا من المشهد الانتخابي
والتصويت عبر البريد والتهديدات باستخدام
العنف ابرز الاسباب التي ادت الى القلق من
امكانيه خطف الديمقراطيه
المدينه الهامه في بنسلفانيا حضرنا ندوه
اعدها افراد فاعلون من المجتمع يحاولون
التحضير من المخاطر التي تهدد الديمقراطيه
الامريكيه ويحاولون توعيه الناخبين حول
الادلاء باصواتهم وضمان احتساب خياراتهم
دون الخوف من الغائها
العداله الاجتماعيه ونظرا الى اننا سنشهد
وبعد اسابيع قليله الانتخابات النصفيه
نعتقد انها ستكون فرصه جيده لمراجعه اهم
القضايا نحن الان في وضع سياسي مختلفه
تماما وقسم كبير من بلدنا توقف عن الايمان
بموسقيه وفعاليه الانتخابات
المخاوف وكانت كبيره لدى السكان هنا في
بيت سبورت فلا يمكن ان ننسى الجدل الكبير
في الانتخابات الماضيه حول عمليات تزوير
طالت النتائج وعدت لفوز المرشح الديمقراطي
انا ذاك والرئيس الحالي
ان يتاكد من ان صوته وصل الى مكتب
المقاطعه وتم اكتسامه واذا ما اختار
التصويت في مراكز الاختراع فيمكن التاكد
عنه فيمكن التاكد ان صوته سيحتسب اما
التصويت بشكل مباشر في مراكز التصويت فهو
الطريقه الاضمن
النقاش حول امكانيات اي تزوير في
الانتخابات المقبله بدا العقبات التي قد
تعترض المسار الديمقراطيه عديده تتم
مراقبتها من قبل خبراء وحقوقيين على امل
ان تطمئن الناخب من نزاهه الانتخابات ريتا
سليمان العربيه تنسلفانيا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الجزائريه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في مجلس النواب في حال فوز الجمهوريين من
هو كيفن مكرره
[موسيقى]
وانضم الينا من واشنطن الباحث في الشان
الامريكي احمد الحنطي اهلا بك سيد احمد
معنا في هذه التغطيه الخاصه سيد احمد يعني
العديد من
المترشحين لهذه الانتخابات من الجمهوريين
تحديدا هم من رافدين نتائج انتخابات عام
2020 ماذا يمكن ان يحصل هل يمكن ان نتوقع
فوضى كابتل اثنين كما حصل بذلك العام همم
هل يمكن ان يرفضوا لدرجه الفوضى
يعني
الفوضى نعم ولكن اقتحام الكبتل اعتقد ان
هذا سيحدث لانه يعني ما في ما في حدث معين
خاص يتم فيه اعتماد الفائزين في مكان واحد
ليجتذب يعني المثير شغب من كل انحاء
امريكا كما حدث في سته يناير ولكنه قد
تحدث عمليات فوضى متفرقه
قد يؤثر اكثر على المستقبل
نتائج الانتخابات سيفوز كثير منهم كثير
منهم فوزهم مضمون اصلا فبالتالي ماذا
سيفعل بعد ان يفوز اذا كان قبل ان يدخل
الانتخابات يقول انه يقبل النتائج بالتالي
بعد ان يفوز عندما يصبح هو من لديه سلطه
اصدار القرار الم يعرف نتائج الانتخابات
مستقبلا هذا ما سن رائع يعني في الفتره
القادمه
عن مخاوف امنيه حتى انه الرئيس تتحدث عن
مخاوف حقيقيه
والاعلام الامريكي رفض نقل رصد متخصصين
لتزايد في نشاط المجموعات اليمنيه
المتطرفه
ومشاركتهم بمظاهرات عنيفه
احداث متفرقه يعني انه يحدث احداث عنف في
اكثر من مكان ولكن ليست بحجم ما حدث في
الكبتل في سته يناير
شاهدنا مثلا في متشجن يعني في الله اثناء
ازمه الكوفيت عندما حاصر يعني قصر الحاكم
وعلقوا يعني كانوا مسلحين وكانوا يهددون
بالشنخل الحاكمه همم هذه الاحداث قد تصبح
اكثر
هذه الانتخابات يقال بانها استفتاء على
شعبيه بايضا هل يمكن في حال وصول
الجمهوريين وسيطرتهم على الكونجرس ان همم
يشبر بيضا على التنحي وعدم الترشح
بالانتخابات القادمه
قد يكون لها تاثير داخل الحسبه الديمقراطي
لانه يعني نحتاج لقياده جديده ولكن
التاثير لن يكون كبير لانه خساره
الديمقراطيين لاغلبيه المجلس النواب
بالذات والشك في خساره تغلبيه مجلس الشيوخ
كانت متوقعه من اشهر ليست يعني حدث مفاجاه
ليست خساره خارج المالوف هذا كله ضمن
المقلوب وحدث لجميع الرؤساء في الفتره
الاخيره يعني حدث مع حدث مع ترامب وحدث مع
اوباما وحدث مع كلينتون مع بوش الابن يعني
حدث ولكن متاخر لانه احداث 11 سبتمبر وحرب
العراق اجلت اجلت التاثير بعض الشيء ولكنه
حدث بعد ذلك فيعني لا يوجد حدث خاص يؤكد
يجبر بيض يعني يسحب يسحب ترشيحه
ولكنه قد يعطي دفعه يعني للمنافسين لمن
يرغبون في المنافسته انه الرئيس كبير في
السن صحته يعني ليست جيده بكثيره نحتاج
لدماء جديده نحن احتجناه في الفتره
الماضيه ليحزم ترامب هو اعزمه ترامب
حاليا لا يوجد اسماء بارزه لا يوجد لانه
لا احد يجرؤ على طرح اسمه كبديل الى ان
يعلم بايضا انه لن يترشح قبل ذلك الجميع
سيظل يعمل في الخفاء يعني يمكن ابرز
الاسماء حاليا حكيم كاليفورنيا
مم طيب سيد احمد بافتراض خساره الحزب
الديمقراطي لهذا الانتخابات النصفيه بشكل
واسع او حتى جزئي يقال داخل الامريكي
سيتحول بيضن الى بطه عرجاء وستتم عرقله
العديد من الملفات ولن يكون قادرا على
تنفيذ السياسات التي وعد بها عند وصول الى
البيت الابيض ما هي اهم الملفات التي قد
يعرقلها الجمهوريون
بالنسبه
تشريعيه لبيض معظمها مر يعني ما يمكن
مروره مر فعلا ما لم يمر اصلا من الصعب
ضروري ولكنه سيعطلون بالذات له ولو خسر
الديمقراطيون اغلبيه مجلس الشيوخ سيكون
هناك تعطيل كامل تعيينات القضائيه هذه
يعني اكبر مشكله ستواجه بايضا همم يعني
عين عدد كبير جدا من القضاه في السنتين
الماضيتين باعتماد الاغلبيه الموجوده في
مجلس الشيوخ وما زال امامه ينوي تعيين
المزيد والمزيد خلال الفتره القادمه هذا
سيتعطل تماما كما حدث في اخر سنتين من حكم
اوباما عندما عطل الجمهوريون جميعا
التعيينات القضائيه بما فيها يعني كان
مقعد في المحكمه العليا
احمد الحمدي
[موسيقى]
يوتيوب
[تصفيق]
تفيض بما يعرقل تقدم مسيرته السياسيه مع
تقدمه المقترض بالعمر المتابعه
[موسيقى]
توليفه من زله اللسان والقدم غير مبشره
للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدنا وضعت ليقته
الذهنيه والبدنيه في خانه الشك واثرت على
الصوره الاداره الديمقراطيه قبل انتخابات
التجديد النصفيه
قوي
[موسيقى]
في الرئيس الامريكي دائما التلاحمه تتوه
عنه الاسماء والصفات الوظيفيه لاهم اعضاء
فريق
الدفاع حين ويصف نائبته بالسيده الاولى
احيانا اخرى
[موسيقى]
اعلام
مصافحه الهواء واستبدال سوريا بليبيا
والشعب الاوكراني بالايراني وغضب بوتن
لروسيا عناوين مجموعتها فواتا تلاحق بيضا
وتلصق به صفات الخلف احيانا
لكنها لا تلخص متاعب بيضا جميعها
من الهزائم الاقتصاديه تمثلت بوصول معدلات
التضخم لاعلى مستوياتها منذ 40 عاما نتج
عنها ارتفاع تكلفه المعيشه وانهيار قيمتي
ومكاسب اجور جميع العاملين كما يؤخذ على
بيض كيفيه التعامل مع رائحه كورونا ابناء
بيضا الذين يخطئوا باسمائهم ايضا يضيفون
الى سلسله الاخفاقات هذه ونقاط الضعف
السياسي حيث يخضع نجله هنتر لتحقيقات
فيدراليه منذ اربعه اعوام على خلفيه تهمه
فساد والادلاء ببيانات كذبه لشراء سلاح
تصويت عقابي ينتظر صاحبه 79 عاما في
الانتخابات النصفيه اولا قبل الامتحان
الحقيقي بعد عامين ان بقي على نيه الترشح
لا سيما انه يواجه ادنى نسبه تاييد
تاريخيه على الاطلاق والمخدره بثلاثه
وثلاثين في المئه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انت عاد اذن هذه الساعه لكن التغطيه لا
تزال مستمره مع الزملاء طاهر وصهيب والمحل
[موسيقى]